i was always told in the beginning that
you're not allowed to use go to
statements that's really bad programming
is this correct or not jumping around
code can can we look at the philosophy
and the technical
uh aspects of the go-to statement that
seems so convenient but it's supposed to
be certainly back in the day in basic
programming languages you didn't have
proper loops you didn't have four whiles
and repeats you know that was the land
of pascal for people that kind of
generally had access to it back then so
you had no choice but to use go to's and
as you made what were big programs back
then which were a thousand line basic
program is a really big program they did
tend to sort of degenerate into madness
uh you didn't have good editors or code
exploration tools so you would wind up
fixing things in one place add a little
patch and there's reasons why structured
programming generally helps
understanding but go-to's aren't
poisonous sometimes they're the right
thing to do usually it's because there's
a language feature missing like nested
breaks or something where it's it can
sometimes be better to do a go-to
cleanup or go-to error rather than
having multiple flags multiple if
statements littered throughout things
but but it is rare if you grip through
all of my code right now i am i don't
think any of my current code bases would
actually have a go to but uh deep within
sort of the technical underpinnings of a
major game engine you're going to have
some go-to's in a couple places probably
yeah the infrastructure on top of like
the closer you get to machine code the
more goatees you're going to see the
more of these like hacks you're going to
see because uh the set of features
available to you in low-level
programming languages is not
as limited
you